avec nous maintenant direct de vancouver
le ministre guette un bar est
responsable la santé des services
sociaux monsieur barrette bonsoir
bonsoir on vient de voir dans ce
reportage on s'était parlé avant noël on
s'en souvient de cette question des
soins à domicile
on vient de voir dans ce reportage des
personnes âgées qui disent recevoir
moins de services à domicile entre
autres des bains onat à six mois dans
certains cas alors qu'en campagne
électorale javier promis plus de soins à
domicile
oui et c'est la réalité je me souviens
qu'avant noël lorsque nous avions une
autre conversation vous et moi je vous
avais dit que j'allais vérifier les
chiffres il vous en faire part à la
première occasion je suis heureux d'être
avec vous ce matin c'est être ce soir
pardon à la réalité
monsieur roy elle est très simple la
réalité est que tant qu'on compare 13 14
avec 14 15 on comprendra 14 kinsella
dernières données disponibles
on a au québec a augmenté de 11 % le
nombre d'heures de services donnés aux
personnes à domicile et on a augmenté
d'environ 8%
le budget c'est ça la réalité et ça vaut
même dans certaines régions jusqu'à 40
pour sa main sur moi alors je ne
contesterai pas le fait il devint qui
peut qu il peut y avoir des cas
particuliers là qu'ils soient
problématique mais la réalité c'est que
dans notre gouvernement donner des soins
à domicile et d'améliorer la situation
c'est une priorité c'est un engagement
et dans les faits c'est ce qu' on voit
et moi j'ai les cheveux
la réalité c'est ça on l'a donnée là en
13 14 et 14 15 1,3 million d'heures de
services à domicile supplémentaire donc
vous le calcul et en heure de service ce
qui veut dire que pour l'aide à domicile
qui est une partie des soins à domicile
l'inde à domicile les gens comprennent
bien la maison le célibat c'est le
ménage etc pour l'aide à domicile
les chiffres montrent bien cette année
une baisse de
j'ai je parle pas d'armé de budget par
rapport à l'autre année comment vous
expliquez ça là bas c'est à dire que je
sais pas où vous prenez vos chiffres
monsieur roy parce que comme vous venez
de le dire la sela réalise que vous êtes
c'est vrai c'est des bains ces deux
lettres domestiques de l'aide à la vie
quotidienne est institué se sert de ça
ça donne de différentes façons ça peut
se donner par les entreprises d'économie
sociale qui sont en partie subventionné
par le gouvernement il est institué
directement par l'état les six
religieuses dans les faits monsieur roy
la réalité c'est qu'on a augmenté de 11
% le nombre d'heures est d'environ 8
pour c'est le budget par compte
par contre c'est clair que des
évaluations qui sont faites périodiques
par chaque personne qui reçoit des
services doit revoir périodiquement une
évaluation pour voir si la personne
reçoit de bons services le bon soin ça
on le voit mais que vous disiez qu'on
baise le financement je sais pas vous
prenez ces chiffres le shérif eut reçu
pour tout le québec monsieur roy et la
réalité c'est quand les a augmentées je
veux pas entraîner les téléspectateurs
dans un combo chez monsieur bart et puis
c'est pas seul objectif ce que je lisais
devant les yeux les chiffres pour l'aide
je répète c'est l'aide à domicile et non
pas la l'enveloppent général des soins à
domicile
mais pour l'aide à domicile je répète
puisque la somme c'est moins 8,9 pour
cent en dollars cette année qui était
prévu par rapport à l'air moi j'aime
bien ça gueule si vos chiffres à bull et
moi ce que je vous dis là c'est que ce
dont vous parlez c'est inclus dans ce
dont je parle et je le répète parce que
monsieur roy vous ne regardez qu'un
angle et vous leur
regardez sans tenir compte du fait qu'au
cas par cas on doit et on le fait rêver
lui des situations csp qu'une personne
qui vend une période de temps x et eu
besoin d'un bain et que maintenant elle
a besoin de choses du ménage par exemple
alors quand on est sûr vous allez quand
même pas reprocher à notre réseau est à
moi en particulier de ne pas s'adapter
aux patients on doit faire c'est aux
citoyens sur la date et au total de
magie cialis au total ce qui est requis
ce qui est requis par les gens à la
populaire par la population domicile en
fonction de leurs besoins
la totalité de la chose qui modulait
avec le temps la totalité c'est une
augmentation de 11% -3 là quand on dit
ou qu'on fait un reportage en disant on
baisse les services c'est pas la réalité
on adapte ce qui est nécessaire aux
besoins des gens et au total ce que l'on
donne toutes catégories confondues
augmente en art de service et évidemment
en dollars ce qui n'ôte engagement bon
très bien au jeu vous convaincrez pas si
schaeffler pour l'île de montréal ils
sont pour l'un des domiciles
monsieur mais on ne vous reproche rien
opposer question les gens dans le
reportage se posaient des questions
compte tenu que je vais finir avec une
question très sympa là vous aviez promis
150 millions s'en souvient on a parlé la
dernière fois aussi on est rendu à
combien combien vous avez mis de plus en
aide à domicile en soins à domicile
alors au total au moment où on se parle
nous avons augmenté d'environ 100
millions avec la réévaluation des
besoins et moi aussi peut-être je peux
regretter revenir là dessus et monsieur
roy sur l'île de montréal pour
l'ensemble des services à domicile pour
l'ensemble c'est + 19 %
écoutez si vous prenez un
une fraction vous pouvez aller voir les
variations c'est nécessaire c'est clair
par contre au total il y a des
alimentations très bien monsieur
ministre merci de nous avons parlé on va
en reparler sur un sujet qui préoccupe
ceux qui sont comme vous le savez en
demande pour ces services là ils sont
nombreux dans la région de montréal
merci merci et merci de m'avoir laissé
l'opportunité de m'exprimer là dessus et
je croyais - nous aussi ça nous voyons
que beaucoup merci à monsieur le
ministre
merci bonne journée